today i have with me luca luca
lamporiello
who might consider to be the certainly
maybe not in terms of numbers of
language because there's there's moses
out there with i don't know 50
but in terms of pronunciation uh
certainly one of the most accomplished
polyglots in the
polyglottosphere and i want to probe
who is luca why did he become a polyglot
where does that take him so
luca welcome and thank you for being on
my channel thank you for the lovely
introduction steve it's always nice to
to see you to talk to you remember the
last time we we
actually we met i think twice right is
that possible just twice
yeah we did and i think that's it
i think that's no we met some other time
i think i don't know
yeah i think so now you know my when i
first met you like when i first
saw you was when you were looking out
your window
in rome and uh here's this italian guy
now this got to be
12 years ago and and here's this italian
guy and he's speaking english and german
and all this stuff
out of his balcony window in this big
apartment complex in rome and
i thought that was pretty amazing and
here we are 12 or 15 years later
and you have now learned a number of
other languages so
first question to you no first question
is where are you right now because you
travel the world
right now because of the pandemic i am
normally at this time we'll be traveling
around europe especially my beloved
poland
but you know it's been like the last
over the last
i think in the last five years i've
always been traveling between april
and september because as you think i
think you know that in rome it's pretty
warm especially these days
in the summer so i was supposed to be
in poland right now but i'm i'm not
stuck in rome i love it but i'm in rome
right now and i think i'll be in rome
for at least
the next two months i see they're
opening up italy now
opening up the tourists and stuff yep
you know for all the fans of italy all
over the world and i consider myself a
fan of italy
in terms of all the history i've read
about italy i'm traveling in italy
hearing the music of italy we wish italy
the best it's
really really disappointing to see
what's happened and and hopefully
we all come through this we're going to
prevail we're going to
recover italians are very resilient i
know i know the italians
have more savings stocked away than
anybody actually that's true it's true
they're prudent
question luca the polyglot when you were
a boy
10 12 14 did you ever think of yourself
as a future polyglot
i got to tell you the truth uh that at
the age of 12
i didn't myself as a polyglot i didn't
self i didn't see myself
speaking all these languages but one
thing that i do remember very well was
that
my grandmother and my father and my
mother were talking constantly about
learning and about the beauty of
learning about the power of learning
so i remember we were at the summer
house
and then all of a sudden my grandmother
just
said you know she was she was a math
teacher and she told me hey luca do you
want to you know try a little bit of
latin a little bit of mathematics and i
remember as clear as
like as if it were now that i sat down i
was curious and we started doing latin
and french and mathematics and that was
right in the middle of the summer
where i was supposed to be running and
chasing kids and
you know on the on a beach and instead
it was spending
i mean i was not spending the entire
afternoon with her i was spending maybe
some 30
some 30 60 minutes but that i think that
was the moment where my grandmother
planted the seed and the seed was
this thirst for knowledge because a lot
of people
i think they see me as the the polyglot
quote unquote who speaks a bunch of
languages but i live
through languages i live my life through
languages my life does not revolve
in a way it does revolve around
languages but i use
languages i really enjoy the moment
where i can use a language
in order to explore a different world i
don't that
for me languages don't don't happen
don't work in a vacuum
so uh at the age of 12 i
did not think i would become a
politician but i do remember that three
years
later when i was in school i was
scribbling down all the languages that i
wanted to learn i still have it
somewhere
i still have amazing you know the
teacher was giving like a lecture she
was talking about something i was
already writing like 1996.
uh i want to learn this 1997 i want to
learn that i do remember that because i
recently when i was arranging stuff i
found it and i and that actually
happened
so i i think we believe i believe that
we shape our own reality by
thinking and imagining about the things
that are going to happen so at the age
of 15 i was
already aware that i wanted to become a
public but at the age of 12 i was aware
that i wanted to become
a permanent lifelong learner so
what i take from that is that the first
condition of becoming a polyglot is
curiosity the desire to learn
agreed 100 yeah and and that and i share
that entirely
it's it's it's so much fun because of
all the things we discover but by the
age of 15 you are already
called ambitious you are already saying
geez you know not only do i like
learning but i'm setting myself
certain goals so then what was the order
in which you learned
the different languages it's a very good
question at the age of 12
i when i got into middle school in italy
i was learning english
at school until actually from 10 till
13 and then i started learning french
at high school that was the only
language i was learning and at the age
of 15 i started learning german
1996 i remember that there was some ad i
watched on television i just decided to
uh to go for german one year later i was
i started learning
spanish that was in 1998 if i'm not
wrong
actually two years two years later then
i started learning dutch because i met a
stumble upon
i met a dutch girl and three months
later i was writing
love letters and and that was the reason
why i wanted to learn dutch 1999
then i started to learn um after that i
i think it was swedish 20 that was
2002 and then i started learning russian
in 2004 and then
four years later i started learning
mandarin chinese and portuguese that was
in 20
i think was 2008 because i got so
enthusiastic about the responses i
gotten from making a youtube video
right you know that i made that youtube
video on the 22nd of may
2008 and i was in barcelona and
i i honestly thought okay just like you
know for the hell of it i just wanted to
say what the heck i'm just going to make
a video and then the responses were so
positive
so generous generous that i just you
know that
kind of enthused me and pushed me to
learn
languages at a moment a historical
moment of my life where i had
almost given up learning languages
because i told myself okay i've been
learning a bunch of languages that's
fine
and i didn't know where life would bring
me because i was
on the path of you know i wanted to
become an uh
uh an engineer and then that reignited
the the power the beauty and the will to
learn languages and then
after that i started learning uh
japanese
and now that's 2008. 2008 i started
learning mandarin
and portugal when was the big sort of
turning point after the
the famous video in the window i thought
it was rome turns out it's barcelona
it was barcelona yeah it was like the
very first video was in barcelona all
the other videos i made after that were
in my at my
sister's apartment in rome and i when i
went back all right
um so that was a turning point i would
say that the two
main turning points of my life as a
polygon life
are um in 1996 when i discovered my
bi-directional translation method you
know that i use a certain method to
discover
another language and i uh
i was 15 and i applied that with with
german and the second breaking
that breakthrough was when i uh started
uh
making youtube videos because i just
realized that
i was not alone first there was a
community out there
and third i really learned because my
thought
i thought that when you when you live in
uh you like i didn't know a lot of
other polyglots out there so what
happened is that when you discover
people
like steve steve you were one of the
first i discovered uh stu j ray
or professor aguelis or richard simka i
discovered that people
learned in very different ways so i
integrated you know i started
integrating and understanding more
principles and integrating what was good
and what i liked of their method
and that changed everything and i kind
of remember you you talked about this
as well i said oh i had my method i was
i was convinced that my method was good
but by learning and by talking to other
people
you know we learn from each other that's
the beauty of the internet let me ask
you a question
so uh 2008 2008 but the turning point
2015 was a point
turning point so if we say 2008
you already had if i remember now you
had of course
italian spanish french english
mandarin like you had like half a dozen
languages at least under your belt
so how many languages have you learned
since then
from 2008 yeah that's a good question uh
well if you consider to thought the
moment
i started learning mandarin was 2008 if
you include that that would be mandarin
portuguese japanese hungarian
greek and i'm learning i'm currently
learning danish so
that would be six yeah and now i'm i'm
i've been learning 14 languages always
plus
latin but latin is not a language i
speak so i wouldn't consider that
so now i have so many questions i want
to ask you but
first simple question when we are always
asked like how many languages do you
speak
in my own case you know i can give a
total number of the languages that i
have studied
and let's say half of them i can speak
now
and half of them i would have to kind of
refresh them in order to be
actually able to carry on a conversation
even though at one point when i was
visiting crete
i could speak greek if you came at me in
greek right now i would be totally
tongue-tied
in your case 14 languages you can turn
them all on
or there's some that maybe you'd be a
bit tongue-tied
i would be tongue-tied especially in
japaneses i originally made a video
about
that that i don't speak it fluently by
any stretch of the imagination or
um there's a couple of languages that i
would not be able to speak right now
would be very tongue-tied because these
are languages that i don't speak very
often
that would be mandarin chinese right now
japanese um
that would be i think these two
particularly
and in general i think that what we have
to consider a lot of people do not
consider that is that
polyglot people multilingual people's
abilities vary with time
so it means that it means that at a
certain point of time because of
uh personal reasons when i had for
example my uh when i was in a
relationship with my ex russian
girlfriend
my russian was very very smooth i could
speak it because i spoke it
every single day but in like there's
a lot of there's two main differences
that there's two main factors that you
have to
take into account when it comes to
language learning there's two things one
is storage
and the other one is retrieval meaning
that
we store things in our long-term memory
so i have
i have russian stored i have a lot of
info i have a lot of words etc
but retrieval is the mechanism that
becomes a little bit rusty you can
imagine like a mechanical arm that go
that goes and matches words that you
need for a conversation
if you don't speak the language that
often plus you might have interference
from other languages
then that becomes rusty so in my case my
russian right now is not as good as it
was and my polish
now is much better in terms of my
russian
is better in terms of knowledge but my
polish is
is more fluent because i use it more
often so to answer your question
i would say that out of the 14 languages
that i
have been learning i would would say
that i
speak at the drop of a hat if you ask me
hey let's have a conversation and say
whatever language
is under your belt i would say 10
languages is a safe number where
i could hold a conversation and
um i i could i could i would say enjoy
the conversation
there are different degrees of obviously
fluency in some languages like
english or spanish or italian or uh or
french for that matter i would be able
to express myself very fluently right
it's never it's never a zero-sum game
it's never either you speak or you don't
right there's
there's so many shades right
exactly and then you have the people who
say yeah but you made a mistake in
in your spanish or you you didn't know
the word for something
which doesn't matter at all you know
sometimes you get people saying well if
you don't know how to say
tie your shoelaces in a language then
you can't claim to speak it there are
always holes it doesn't matter how well
you speak a language
i think i speak french quite well but i
know if i ever listen to myself in an
interview i'll see ah i made a mistake
there i made a mistake there
there's always holes so this is
perfection is not the goal
i i think i think there's this kind of i
call it the youtube syndrome
yeah it's like the perfectionist
syndrome some people a lot of comments
that you get
is more says more about the people who
left the comment than
actually about you that's always the
case and everything because when people
tend to be very
critical of the single and some mistakes
you made
they're maybe not that sure of
themselves because a person
who is has a positive attitude towards
learning as a person who takes oh wow he
always sees the
glass half full and say hi what can i
learn what do i admire of this person
how can i learn from this person instead
of seeing oh the holes and you
will never speak any language perfectly
including our own does not exist making
mistakes is the best
thing that can happen to you if you want
to learn okay that's how it works
no i have two other things i want to get
to one is
the method so you said that in
maybe 2008 you discovered your
bi-directional
translation method how does that work
and including that what are some of the
principles
that you use to learn these many
languages and to speak them
despite what we just said at a very high
level all of them i've heard you
obviously in russian you've lived in
russia but you speak phenomenally well
but
even when we had our conversation in
mandarin and japanese you're very very
good so so what's the method thank you
thank you you're always flattered me too
much steve i just well just one thing
i've never lived in russia
the only countries i lived in are spain
and france
just too sorry but you visited or you
never visited i
spent i spent i mean i i spent
i was there three times for for a stint
for a period of three weeks because i
visited my girlfriend
all right anyway hey it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
thank you so um to answer to your
question
the method is called the bidirectional
translation method
it's not it's not a method to learn a
language fully it's
it's there's a like a lot of
misunderstandings around this for me
this method is a method where i use my
own native language as a crutch
or i leverage the knowledge i have in my
own native language in order to dissect
understand and absorb the the the main
structures the main patterns
of uh any other foreign language so
basically i use texts
i use i start with a beginner's material
that
normally contains a bilingual version
meaning the
you have the my own native language on
the one side
and then i have the the other language
on the other side
and then i translate first i
dissect the text then i translate it
into my own native language onto a piece
of paper or to a google docs because i
personalize this because a lot of people
say oh why would you do that if you
already have the text in your own native
language
there's a lot of reasons why and then
after a couple of days
timing is really important because of
space-time system and how our
brain remembers i translate it back into
uh the language i am learning and i have
found this to be an extremely effective
method that was the break the first
breakthrough 1996 when i applied it to
german after
two or three months of uh you know
pounding my head on
the wall not understanding how to deal
with german then i tried this method
and it worked really well and and then
in hindsight i understood that the
reason why this method works really well
is
first of all because i like it because
if you don't like it and
to each his own it's not gonna work you
always have to do something you like in
language learning
never do something you dislike that's
first first
that's what i discovered second i
discovered that it works so well
because you you might have noticed this
is ironic that in
around the world people at school do not
in class
in classrooms normally they do not learn
languages well it's very rare that a
person learns a language after going to
school
right and i've been wondering why does
that why is that
why doesn't it work but why does this
education system or
does not work well this is goes beyond
the scope of this conversation the
education system and why
is outdated but in terms of language
learning i think that one of the reasons
why this doesn't work is that
adults have the capacity of learning
languages like steve
uh steve krashen says it too the only
problem is that we often
sabotage ourselves and do it backwards
just to give an idea
to me comprehensible input is really
important that is a
condition like that's the most important
condition obviously that's the factor
but the other factor if you think about
it is that we have two different
circuitry in our brain
one is declarative memory and the other
one is procedural memory so in
other words for those who are not
familiar with the terms declarative
memory is something that has to do with
how many words
you you acquire right let's the pieces
of information like dates
like uh you know names uh words in a
foreign language
the other one is called procedural or
implicit memory and has to do with how
we form
sentences so if you observe a
five-year-old kid
speaking their own native language they
speak their language perfectly
albeit but they do not know a lot of
vocab right
so what this method does is that it
actually
and it actually activates both
circuitries of our brain
you learn words but you always learn
words by
embedding them in sentences when you
translate something
you're transferring a thought from one
your native language
into your into a foreign language by not
just
translating the single words but doing
it backwards it's always the meaning
and then you have the words as a
consequence of that you have to imagine
like having a spider web
you build a structure and the words get
stuck in there like
like flies so um and
it i mean it takes time to explain but i
in hindsight i've realized that this
works very well because i
tested it on myself and it worked
wonderfully well but i've been
i've been training hundreds of people in
the last over the last i've been i'm a
language coach i've been
i've been training hundreds of people i
don't think there's anyone who disliked
this method
the people who wanted to take it just
took it they loved it you know
with one caveat which is very important
this is not a method
that is after which if you apply for
three months you're going to be speaking
a language right
far from that this method doesn't exist
it does you it well let's put it this
way
it exists in so far as it's a
combination of methods that evolve with
time no no sorry what i meant to say is
the method whereby you go from zero to
speaking fluently in three months
doesn't exist well in my you can you can
learn to say a few things
in three months and sound fluent but in
my experience
in order to be comfortable speaking a
language you actually need
a lot of words and a lot of familiarity
with the language which is not acquired
in three months
i would say this i would say this uh
first let me finish describing this
method and then i'll tell you what i
think about this
um so by applying this method at the end
of the
three month or four month period that
helps you
actually familiarize yourself with the
basic structures your brain
is more um absorbs better understands
better and then when you go and look
maybe at some grammar notes you
understand things oh well
down the line you understand things that
were not clear before so
but again in three months i would say
that the only chance that i always say
that well can you learn can you learn to
speak a language in in three months
the only possibility that you have to
speak a language and it again it depends
on what you mean by speak
right to speak a language in three
months i would say to have a hold a
conversation would be
if the language were very close to yours
if you had a lot of time at your hand
if you lived in that country if you had
a partner speaks the language
if you spoke 10 hours a day then in that
and if you have
if you're an experienced polyglot that
okay but normally
over like if you consider the entire
spectrum
it's not gonna let's say that if if you
have spanish and you want to learn
italian and you're living in italy
three months is ample you'll do it yeah
but that's awesome
greek mm-hmm it's a little more
difficult greek is a little more
difficult turkish is even more
complicated
i mean it on a scale to like i would say
if i like from the point
of view you always have to consider your
native language italian in my case
the closest language in terms of not
only structure syntax and
vocab and whatnot is spanish not even
portuguese
because the pronunciation and the
intonation are quite similar right
uh again three months but you have to be
like really focused 10 hours a day in
the environment and everything else and
for most cases i would say it takes
a lot of time it like the brain does
something amazing
it's called also the compound effect if
you learn every day for a long period of
time
time will be your best friend so don't
be in a rush because if you try to cram
as much information as possible in three
months
right then you're gonna forget
everything so it's a it's so it's always
a marathon it's
never ever a sprint no no look uh i'm
gonna leave a link
in the description box to where they can
find you for people who want to pursue
this translation
method we're also going to have an
interview later on for your
youtube channel where you can ask me all
kinds of questions
uh but i certainly must say that that
what you said there
you know people sometimes say well you
should only use a monolingual dictionary
and blah blah blah
i think relating and similarly with the
grammar
um you know not emphasizing the grammar
until you've had enough experience with
the language
i have always found that i learned you
know this is the way we say it
in chinese this is how we say it in
english i have never
understood any of the grammatical terms
or grammatical explanations
i related to my language or a language
that i know very well
this is how they say in this new
language this is how
we say it in a language that i'm
familiar with and i i kind of connect
the two
without any intermediary explanation
grammatical terms and all the stuff
which just confuses me
so to that extent i and i i must admit
the other thing you said which i heart
wholeheartedly agree with is you have to
like the method you're using
and you have to believe in the method
and stay with
it so if someone starts that
bi-directional translation
method and maybe i should try that for
arabic where i'm struggling
uh you have to believe in it you have to
like doing it and if you do that you'll
succeed
that's absolutely true you're a wise man
steven no i'm not
i'm an older man than you though so
let's finish off with
so where does this take you
um you love languages i love languages
you are a language coach is that the
ultimate goal
are you still exploring new languages
what does the next five years look like
for luca oh that's a big question um
i could not anticipate too much but i
would just say that
the direction that the the path that
i've taken is a mission
for not just education in terms of
language learning but education in
general my
my mission is to help
people be more aware of the power of
education and self-education so it's a
broader scope so when i see myself
is like doing something and reaching
millions of people whether it's possible
or not a lot life will allow me to do
that
and see how like language learning is
just one
part of the entire thing it's a matter
of awareness being a citizen of the
world
self-education through language learning
i have realized
a number of things that most people uh
are oblivious of and i'm not saying that
i'm like
the enlightened one right far from that
i'm just understood
through language learning that a lot of
people think in the box instead of
outside of the box and they don't see
the possibilities
that the power of education can convert
their lives in terms of
imagine the amount of people nowadays
who have the internet at their disposal
but they don't know what to do
when it comes to learning a language
they don't know how to use the the tools
that they have they're they're confused
by the amount
of possibilities and websites and
platforms imagine being able
to have that clarity over like
for a lot of other things like sports uh
awareness
that is where this is taking me because
i'm becoming more and more aware i'm
in in a path where language learning is
does
occupy some place but i'm doing like i'm
delving into neuroscience
coaching psychology leadership history
philosophy it's it's i'm i've become
i'm a very very different person than i
was five years uh
before and i've learned that the best
mission that i can have in my life
is not for is not about myself is to
serve other people to help people
see what they can still cannot see and
what i've seen not because i'm better
than anybody else but because
i had the luxury given life has given me
the luxury and the possibility
of realizing this at the ripe age of 39
39 wow okay well listen
we will uh we will be
picking up this conversation on your
channel and
but i thank you very much and of course
it's not possible in 25 minutes to cover
all the subjects that we would like to
cover together maybe we should do this
from time to time
but thank you very much for joining me
what is
so where can people find you people can
find me on
www.lucalamparelo.com or
just by typing luca lampariello on
google
and they will find my youtube i also
have a youtube channel that goes by the
name of luca allen parelo no fantasy
there
so if you type luka pedal on google on
youtube and
on you will find my blog and you will
find my youtube channel
and um you know i'm there to help you
and serve you guys the last thing i
wanted to say
steve is i think that since you're an
interesting guy hopefully i'm also an
interesting guy and people might have a
lot of questions
maybe they can have questions and we can
collect them for another video and they
can ask us all the questions
please put your questions in the comment
area we're going to leave a link to
lucas uh you know various presences on
the internet
and hopefully there's a conversation we
can continue
thank you steve okay thank you luca ciao
[Music]
foreign